I wanted to kick it off
by acknowledging someone I found out was a childhood idol.
We have a picture.
(chuckles)
Yes.
That was like the main reason I picked up drumsticks.
I loved that so much
because I was such a fan too, growing up.
And we're both born,
I believe 1975?
Yes.
And you have kids?
You're so our older, though.
Yeah. So I have three kids.
I have my youngest daughter.
Alabama's 15.
My son Landon is 17.
And then,
my oldest daughter Atiana is 21
who I've raised since she was two years old.
And yeah, I, I, my kids are almost seven and almost nine.
And this is such a tricky time
for kids that age with school and a year long of homeschool.
Yeah.
I mean, you just got to think
of the positives that we get to spend so much time with them
and kind of like,
not worry about the hustle of taking them to school
and bringing them back home from school.
So that's been really, really awesome just by default.
And then just taking this time to like,
learn something new or like thrive and,
and kind of dig deep.
Like I started producing a ton during this time.
So there's just been like blessings upon blessings
that have happened during this time as well
Being a producer.
I think that, you know,
I believe that I'm still around
because I got involved behind the scenes.
Did you think like that,
was it conscious or did you just love what you did
and knew so much about it that you like, what was
what was your catalyst for wanting to take on more?
For me, I obviously was like really into playing the drums
and being the best drummer I could
and it was constantly practicing
but I felt like I always had this
this longing and this desire to help arrange the music
or not have a bridge.
Like I was, I was always so active
in giving my input and all that.
And then that really, really came
to fruition when I was in Blink.
And, you know, in Enema of the State
was our groundbreaking album.
That really was an essential album for us.
And I think that was the first one I got to write
and help arrange and really be a part of the songwriting.
And that, from that point on
I knew that that was something I wanted to do.
And I had like a talent besides just playing drums.
Well, then there's another side of it where you're like,
okay I am this thing.
I love everything about it.
I live my life through it,
but then you grow and you change
and you want to get involved.
And I love branding.
I love advertising.
I love creating things.
And so there's also more than not only
so many things in one aspect.
There's more than just the one aspect of people
in you have started this wellness line,
Barker wellness.
And will you tell us about it?
It's beautiful, by the way.
Oh, thank you.
You know, I love vigorous touring
and that schedule playing six to seven shows a week for,
you know, sometimes 15 weeks at a time.
Recovery became like a big issue for me
just figuring out this does Epsom salt bass work?
Does cryotherapy work for me?
Does CBD work for me?
And I just started really, really experimenting with it all.
And I found that CBD was like a big, big, big, you know
helpful recovery tool for,
for touring and just recovery after exercising.
And two years later,
Barker wellness was born.
I just basically did it because I was using all this product
and it was such,
it was so helpful.
It was life-changing.
I wanted to ask you
because you do just have such an incredible attitude.
And I feel like, I don't know.
I just relate to you in a lot of ways.
We both been living out there, you know
with our lives sort of like open book style
having kids reacting to that as parents.
Do you like,
I'm also like a Doberman with my kids
because of my upbringing.
How are you with your kids with like, you know
your advice of having them be out there or not?
So my kids have been touring with me since they were two.
So I think I can't protect them from everything.
I can't shelter them from everything.
All I can do is kind of, you know
show them what doors I walked through
and what worked for me and what didn't work for me and,
you know protect them and guide them as much as I can.
I love your answer.
And I read a note that your lovely lady wrote to you saying,
like, "We may destroy each other."
And I was like, "Oh, that's so hot."
And I think my love note might be like,
"Can we just get to bed early and like watch a movie?"
So funny.
Yeah, I would, I would prefer the opposite.
I would prefer to, you know
kind of go and blaze of glory, like ball of flames.
Now I'm dating again.
I had a weird question
and if you're not comfortable talking about it, forget it.
But I wanted to ask advice, which is like
if you date someone and you have children
do you think it's better to date someone
with kids and then they'll understand your life or say,
"It doesn't matter if they don't have kids",
then you can like have fun adventures
and just like, you know kind of get out of that mind frame.
So I've done both.
Yeah.
But up until now, like I would, you know
like date girls that didn't have kids
and I find it kind of hard because they would,
I think they would have trouble understanding like,
well, why don't you want to go
to dinner every night with me?
Or why don't you want to see me every night?
And now I'm,
you know, spending time with a woman who's like a great mom.
Who's like a great friend.
And I just,
you don't have to worry about any of those things.
It just comes natural.
It's like a maturity thing.
Yeah.
And, and I also really like missing someone and
and cherishing the time that I spent with them
instead of, you know, every day being with them
or especially in the beginning of the relationship
I think like missing someone so important.
Yep.
It's so true.
(upbeat music)